hi everyone so this is the fourth video
in a lecture series on exponential
growth and I've walked you through all
of these great examples of how
exponential growth is everywhere and
describes you know Bunnie populations
and fission the stock market you know
all of these exponential growth
processes and now I'm really excited to
tell you kind of where this ends and
that in practice exponential growth
doesn't actually really exist in any
system forever so even if you have a
system that's really well modeled by
exponential growth eventually something
is going to stop your system from going
exponentially because you know there's
finite resources on earth there's finite
resources in the solar system and the
galaxy eventually you're gonna hit some
limit where you can't keep growing
exponentially okay so we had talked
about you know doubling of populations I
this is an example I actually cooked up
this morning because I think it's kind
of a fun example is if you go back and
count kind of your family tree and how
many ancestors you have so this is me I
had two parents as most of us do and my
two parents each had two parents and
their two parents had two parents and
this kind of leads to a paradox I think
a lot of kids have had figured this out
pretty early that the logical
progression of this doesn't really make
sense so if I double the amount of
ancestors I have every every generation
I go back very quickly within about a
thousand years let's say that that's 50
generations I will have quadrillions of
ancestors and that doesn't make sense we
don't think that there have been
quadrillions of humans on earth okay and
so there's a pretty simple solution to
this and that's basically that at some
point my ancestors were all kind of
mixed up and we're all like we are all I
don't want to say this at some point
every ancestor on every branch is not
unique these people become cousins at
some point and maybe my third
great-grandfather was also
my third great-granduncle on a different
branch because they're the same person
because family trees don't just branch
forever at some point your ancestors
will come back and multiple points and
although this grows exponentially
eventually it kind of can't grow any
more because there aren't there weren't
that many people who existed and this
goes to show that basically everybody on
planet Earth are cousins at some level
back we had to be or else there would be
quadrillions of people in our ancestor
tree okay so all of us are like 10th or
20th or 30th cousins maybe 50th cousins
with one another that's kind of a fun
example of how exponential growth can't
possibly go forever okay so if we go
back to our bunny population so we've
seen you know this kind of cutesy
example of how two bunnies become for
bunnies for bunnies become eight bunnies
we know that they double in double and
double but this can't go on forever okay
so my neighborhood my backyard whatever
the environment where these bunnies live
can't support infinity bunnies and so
eventually something is going to cause
this to stop growing and so that's what
I'm going to talk about now are some
examples of how exponential growth
naturally does saturate at some point so
this was our differential equation for
bunnies it gave this nice exponential
growth but if you have limited resources
like a limited planet Earth or let's say
a limited you know I've got bunnies in
my backyard but only so many of them can
live because there's only so much food
only so much lettuce and carrots you can
modify the equation so it's still the
same basic part you get this exponential
growth but there's this correction term
that tells you that there is a maximum
carrying capacity in your neighborhood
or on earth so big X is the most bunnies
that your environment can can handle
before some of them start to starve okay
so big X maybe it's a million bunnies
maybe it's a thousand bunnies I don't
know in my case I picked 40 bunnies so
big X is 40 that's as much as my
backyard can handle and so what you'll
see is that as your population gets
closer and closer to the maximum this
gets closer and closer to one
and your exponential growth gets
multiplied by a number that it gets
closer and closer to zero so slows your
exponential growth so if I started with
two bunnies after one year I'm still
gonna get four bunnies after two years
I'm still gonna have eight bunnies but
very quickly I'm running out of
resources and so this number is getting
closer to zero and my rate of growth is
decreasing and it decreases more and
more faster and faster as I get to this
carrying capacity big X and so you see
that this is a very simple mechanism for
my exponential growth to curtail and to
eventually hit some some maximum value
so this is sometimes called a sigmoid
function this is called the logistic
equation it's super important in
dynamical systems in lots of systems
there have actually been some great
YouTube videos on the logistic equation
that I'll link to pretty sure veritasium
did a really really nice one recently on
this equation okay so that's one way the
exponential growth curtails in in
population dynamics now another way that
exponential growth can curtail I have
the same bunnies given by X so X is my
population of bunnies XK plus 1 is my
number of bunnies next year R is my
birthrate what if I have wolves what if
there's some predator species my wolves
are Y ok the population of wolves is
given by Y and we know that wolves eat
bunnies and that's going to keep these
bunnies from growing exponentially
because if I get more and more and more
bunnies I'm going to get more and more
and more wolves that eat those bunnies
and eventually I'm going to hit some
kind of a balance point and notice that
this term here is pretty interesting
it's nonlinear and what this says is
that the number of bunnies that get
eaten is proportional to how many
bunnies there are if I have twice as
many bunnies probably twice as many are
going to get eaten but it's also
proportional to how many wolves there
are if I have twice as many wolves I'm
going to eat twice as many bunnies and
so the rate in which Wolves eat bunnies
is proportional to x times y and E is
just a constant that tells you know how
how frequently wolves come in contact
with bunnies and eat them okay so this
is gonna balance out that exponential
growth because the faster they grow the
more wolves are gonna eat them now of
course there is an equation for wolves -
so the number of wolves is going to be
and the way we're gonna do this is that
the Wolves are gonna have a natural
death rate so if there's no bunnies the
wolves are just gonna starve to death
and they'll die eventually but they're
going to have new walls new wolves are
gonna be born when they eat enough
bunnies and again they're going to have
a birth rate that's proportional how
many bunnies they eat and how many
bunnies they eat is proportional to x
times y so this is not the right model
this is a very very crude simplistic
model but it illustrates kind of these
population dynamics this is called the
lotka-volterra model and it's really
useful as a toy model for population
dynamics so now let's start the system
off we're not just gonna plot bunnies in
time we're gonna plot bunnies and wolves
in time and I'm gonna start off with 40
bunnies and five wolves and I'm not
gonna have any carrying capacity so the
bunnies could go to infinity now at
after one year the bunnies are growing
exponentially okay after two years
they're still growing but the number of
wolves is growing because there's so
many bunnies
lots of wolves are being born because
they're eating lots of bunnies and
notice that they've already started to
slow down the bunny growth there's now a
lot of bunnies so there's gonna be even
more wolves the next year but because
there's so many wolves the next year
they're eating a lot of bunnies so the
bunny population is dropping
precipitously now a lot of these wolves
are gonna starve because there's not
enough bunnies so now the Wolves are
starting to go down there's still a lot
of wolves so they're eating a lot of
bunnies but now eventually the bunny
that wolf population dies off low enough
that the bunnies start to go exponential
again and then they grow and grow they
hit their peak there's a lot of wolves
and so on and so forth and this repeats
forever okay and you get this kind of
oscillating ebb and flow of bunny and
wolf populations where they oscillate
out of phase with one another now here
you can also write this as a continuous
differential equation the rate of
change of monies the rate of change of
wolves this is actually how you write
down the lock of Volterra systems is a
continuous system but I'm showing you it
just evolving discreetly year to year to
make it simpler okay this is actual data
I really really love this plot this is
data from the Hudson's Bay Company a
trapping company where they counted the
number of pelts of furs bought and sold
of snowshoe hares bunnies and Canada
lynx is their predator and you can see
that I mean the lotka-volterra model is
not perfect but you can absolutely see
that there's this AB and Flo that's kind
of oscillating this oscillating behavior
of the bunny population and the Lynx
population in how many furs were were
trapped and so I like this one right
here so you can see that you know in
this year there were almost no predators
and so the bunny population skyrockets
now because there are so many bunnies
the predator population skyrockets and
because there's so many predators they
eat almost all of the bunnies almost to
extinction and then following the
predator population collapses because
there's no bunnies and then the whole
process repeats itself and it's not
perfectly modeled by the lotka-volterra
system but it's pretty remarkable that
such a simple mathematical system gives
this behavior okay so that's one way of
curtailing exponential growth is through
this kind of multi species interactions
now I'll point out one way I like to
plot this is not just wolves and bunnies
versus time but you can also plot the
number of wolves versus the number of
bunnies and so again we started off with
40 bunnies and five wolves as you
increase time the number of bunnies
increases the number of bunnies
increases and the number of wolves
increases now there's too many wolves so
they eat a lot of the bunnies but
they're still growing now there's less
bunnies so the wolf population collapses
and the whole system goes around and
around and around in this circle this is
called a limit cycle or a periodic orbit
and essentially you go around and around
year to year in this system eventually
every point in the system gets gets
filled out so I really like this way of
plotting it this is called a phase
portrait sometimes but it really really
cool
okay good and the last example I'll talk
about and I'm gonna do a whole video on
this how to model these system so I'm
only going to very briefly talk about it
now is the spread of infectious diseases
so this is the corona virus and some of
our simplest models are these si are
models where you basically break these
are called compartmental models where
you break your population down into a
group of susceptible people these are
healthy people that can get sick you
have infected people people that are
currently sick and you have recovered
people people who were sick and are now
healthy again and can't get sick again
and this is clearly an
oversimplification
sometimes recovered people can get sick
again sometimes people get sick and die
we could add a D for death and but this
is a simplified model called the SAR
model and again it's governed by a very
simple set of differential equations
that someone wrote down so the rate of
change of my susceptible infected and
recovered populations are given by these
functions on the right so there's some
transmission rate that's roughly
proportional to how many susceptible and
infected people there are and there's a
recovery rates from infected to
recovered and with this very very simple
differential equation if you start with
a population in this case let's say it's
a community of 500 people that are
healthy you can watch this progress in
time through this dynamical system and
you can see that for short times the
amount of infected people does grow
exponentially okay when you release a
virus into a new population it grows
exponentially but then as the population
is the susceptible population becomes
infected at an exponential rate this
number decreases and so the base of
people who can get infected goes down
and your infection stops growing
exponentially and eventually curtails as
as those infected people become
recovered okay so even exponential
infection growth eventually saturates
and goes down and here's another way I
like to plot it you've probably seen
this before so now the height of this
blue column is how many healthy
susceptible people there are the height
of this red column or how many infected
people there are and you can watch the
system kind of evolve
in time same exact information just
plotted a different way okay so and of
course these models are imperfect but
they can be useful they can help us
predict kind of how things will evolve
in time what intervention strategies we
need to enact and things like that okay
so exponential growth is ubiquitous it's
everywhere but it only lasts for so long
and then natural processes cause this to
curtail and this brings up some really
important philosophical or moral or
societal questions about how we view
exponential growth in our daily lives so
we've talked about how the economy grows
exponentially the the GDP grows
exponentially technology grows
exponentially with Moore's Law we've had
an exponential growth in connectedness
and our ability to explore and to travel
transportation capabilities have grown
exponentially in time but all
exponential things must end so at some
point Moore's law will stop and our
computers will stop growing bigger
faster perhaps at some point maybe the
economy will stop growing exponentially
I don't know that's something you know
that worries people another concern is
you know our consumption of resources is
growing exponentially so that's an
environmental concern about you know are
we going to fill earth with people and
get denser and denser and are we going
to consume more and more resources until
it becomes a problem until the earth
itself is the feedback mechanism that
corrects and that's actually why I think
a lot of us are so fascinated with space
travel and kind of getting off of this
planet and having more resources in the
solar system and in the galaxy I mean
it's science fiction but we seem to be
driven by this need to grow
exponentially so every time a new
continent is discovered or a new country
industrialize --is or a new resources
found we gobble it up exponentially and
you know at least getting off of planet
Earth gives us a little bit more
exponential growth so anyway I hope this
has been kind of thought-provoking for
you you know exponential growth is seems
like a very simple topic like a you know
an introductory topic in math
but there's a lot of depth and a lot of
kind of nuance to how exponential
processes can be used to model the real
world so I've really enjoyed putting
this lecture series together I hope
you've enjoyed it too if you do please
like please subscribe and hit the
notification so you see when there's new
videos out all right thank you